uh we were able to defeat the last emmy
um and we're on our way
uh we got a new ability and so we're
gonna showcase that
um we're also gonna go a little bit
faster in this segment just to show more
of samus's
really free-flowing movement so speaking
of that new
ability we now have spider magnet
which is really cool now is allowing us
to
climb these blue magnetic strips here
so and samus looks pretty darn cool
while she's climbing i must say
yeah just traverse directly from
horizontal to vertical
there and this uh creature over here is
a blocking
pathway and it's getting a little bit
more jittery as i get closer to it
that's really creepy maybe i can coerce
it out insecty sound
worm door
also note for uh anyone who hasn't yet
seen the first segment this is the first
new 2d metroid in 19 years
so this is very very exciting for for
metroid fans
yeah i liked how you countered that worm
and shot it
yeah so each enemy has like their
patterns to learn so they definitely
want to watch and see how you can
counter them or if you need to
tackle them in a different way oh no oh
so this is
corpus uh he is one of the bosses that
you'll encounter in metroid dread
we happened to see him very briefly
in the first segment it was it was the
very shimmery uh creature that was
lurking in the background
no longer lurking no yeah i know yeah
he's blurping
he just shot that projectile that he
shot out of his mouth and got some
missiles
so having good aim is in your favor here
yeah so it's very key to learn the
boss's patterns but also
find where to hurt them and it looks
like
his face is the weak spot right now
yeah that tail is pretty deadly so you
want to keep your distance
and of course as always you want to keep
an eye on your missile count
yeah so since my missile count is
running low i'm gonna use charge beam
which is also effective
and now he turned invisible great what
he needed was to be invisible that's
what i think
that makes it a little bit harder to
find its face
but i can try otherwise
you could see yep so that little glowy
point
seems to be a weak spot too try to aim
for that
they close shoot it it's a good maxim
for video games in general
got this
and now it's throwing a tantrum so it
broke some of the environment and i see
some blue magnetic
magnetic strips there which i could
probably
use to my advantage oh
and now it reared its ugly head and
turned
to its backside which is probably its
best size
so we're turning here to a cinematic but
i am effectively throwing
missiles at uh corpus's face here
yeah it's another one of those really
dynamic camera angles there
yeah jumping right right into a boss
fight as well why are you back
okay yep so those magnetic strips were
very handy there
yep you have to use all of your
abilities
uh if you're gonna be oops
no and that poison gas doesn't look too
healthy
oh you're mean this one's always trying
to back you into a corner too
it's not very nice
if you if you stay up there hotel will
go for you as well so there's no really
safe spot
oh maybe i can wear it yes
oh that looks stuck buddy
nope missiles yet okay where are you
again
nope tricked me yep
what are you doing oh no i know your
game
no thank you not today oh
i don't think he's gonna like this
he missiles
one last charge beam for effect
i think you got him look at samus
beautiful pose
[Music]
nothing scares salmon
oh look at that spin right through the
tail 10 10.
[Laughter]
get a really good look at her suit here
yeah i'd be watching for a moment too
like are you going down
hold that pose
who what did we get oh yes
of course that's how corpus was turning
invisible
so the phantom cloak was uh previewed
and mentioned by
sakamoto-san in his video earlier this
morning
it is an aon ability and for
some of you at home who have played
metroid samus returns may
recognize ayan abilities but these are
brand new
and they play very differently in
metroid dread
yeah you find new a on abilities and
this one actually uh it's more of an
endurance gauge so it fills up over time
but you really really want to keep a
close eye on it because the last thing
you want is for your
phantom cloak to disappear when you
really need it yeah so let's let's
actually
showcase it here so before i was unable
to go through these doors
um they're called presence doors but now
with the phantom cloak
i'm able to move progress through them
i am moving a lot slower with the
phantom cloak
and as you can see the energy gauge
right underneath
is slowly decreasing but as i move
it decreases even faster and once it's
depleted
it starts taking away from my health so
i have to deactivate it
i can replenish it really quickly by
moving
and then only then can i reactivate it
again
take this elevator up thank you
yeah just like the other abilities this
opens up new areas that you can go and
explore being able to go through those
present stores
so a whole lot more adventure to
to unravel here love this view
that background is so beautiful yeah
this is a new section of this world
filled with magma
just in case
oh those flying guys can be such a
nuisance when you're trying to get
across
oh they can be you handled them very
readily yeah you made that look easy
now flamethrowers
get away from me nice this is
really cool so we're still in the area
of arteria which is the very beginning
part of the game and this is a feature
which is an elevator that allows you to
travel to different parts of planet zdr
um so now we're moving to cataras and as
you can see in the map
this game plays very differently where
you start from the
center core of the planet and you're
working your way up all the way to
samus's ship so
it is a very different feeling really
builds up on the
uh do i say dread isolation
it really does
i showed you had kind of a long way to
go to the surface there too
that little dot at the top was your ship
here's a moment for us to not be you
know attacked and also enjoy this
beautiful hd graphics
a little replay
all right so this is cataracts
let's explore
immediately welcoming committee you
can't
rest on your laurels for a minute in
this game oh yeah not at all
these enemies are different too as you
can see their counter is very
different
but they are really cool very satisfying
to counter
and that place is very hot we don't have
an upgrade for that yet
so we'll have to come back later and
explore it when we do have an available
an ability
to explore it so
ah that looks like an area oh and yes
when in doubt
purple sneaky
no
you never underestimate the little
enemies they can really mess you up
they can especially those they're very
very agile you can see as you learn the
enemy's patterns you can see tells for
when they're about to attack a lot of
times and that'll help you know when
to counter i really love the dash melee
ability
it allows me to effectively get rid of
some enemies really quickly
so this is another communication room
where we'll be able to communicate with
adam
and i kind of want to make it clear too
that
adam is uh samus's uh ship's
computer we're going to skiff through
this area really quickly and have dan
kind of summarize what adam says but
adam is just a point for lore uh
does not do give any direction to samus
it is up to the player to choose where
they want to
navigate and where to explore but yeah
we're only cutting away because we don't
want to
give away any juicy lore tidbits yeah
yeah and basically he was just talking
about how this area is sort of the
thermal
power for um the planet and um
by redirecting that power you can
potentially open up other areas and he
also had a
few little tidbits about the phantom
cloak which we we already knew about how
that gauge worked
thanks to teresa's explanation
all right
oh look in the background you can see
magma flowing through some of those
pipes but
not the others yeah all of these pipes
are very interesting and this mysterious
door open up too
here's an interactable which allows so
this area of cataracts
controls the magma flow of the planet
and so
we're able through these interactables
uh
change the flow to access other areas so
now because we changed the thermal flow
we're not able to backtrack to where we
were
so find a different path
it's such a niche touch that something
we were just talking about in the
background
actually has a game plan component
no
and there we can see that magma flowing
through those pipes
oh and that opened that doorway there
as theresa is very well aware there's
such a diverse
amount of life in in this world so many
different kinds of alien creatures that
maybe not when they're mercilessly
attacking you but it's really neat to
otherwise
see such a different alien creatures
nope no thank you
look at that background let's just
beautiful
oh what's up these these enemies are
pretty
gnarly uh they throw little
uh balls of hurt that i
don't particularly enjoy wow
maybe not stay in the spawning point of
the enemy
a pixelated door you know you're like
what that means
i'm so nervous okay here we go yep so
this door leads to another emmy zone
oh i believe we're gonna that sense of
dread your feeling is very warranted
well i feel it through i feel it their
little beeping
yeah so samus has been able to use the
phantom cloak
to her advantage by escaping
the semi and this emmy can crawl through
tight spaces so
it's pretty formidable um
yeah really liking that phantom cloak
about now
okay i need to not be hearing those
beeps they scare me
watch out oh see it it heard that noise
and so it's now
in yellow mode please don't notice me
well well used phantom cloak there
that saved your tail so you can see in
the mini map
the little red dot is the emmy it is
still nearby
i
making sure that it doesn't hear me okay
we're good
oh oh auto tool oh no
because i wanted to give you some items
no okay maybe i didn't
call the emmy to my no
oh why oh blend in with the background
yeah i i need these guys to just go away
getting some good missiles though
let's see all right i have the
spider magnet ability i should just use
it
all right let's see there's nothing here
sounds like there's something here
there's something no
no no you really want to stay at a
distance
oh i didn't notice you you're so sneaky
emmys because if they get up close and
personal
it's not gonna be in your favor most of
the time
go away let's go home please go away
meanwhile your gauge is just getting
lower and lower
no don't don't don't say that no i mean
fine i mean it's fine it's all fine
i hope okay
yep yep you keep going that way buddy
nothing to see here no it's still there
i think it went the direction that i
wanted to go
no no no no run
can i trick it every bounty hunter for
themselves yep
i'm brave oh
i will escape you
so when it turns and turns red with
pursuit mode it will
still be able to oh you want to charge
hurry hurry
even if you phantom cloak oh no oh no
no the emmys are
brutal cruel to dodge they're nearly
impossible to
uh counter oof all right let's try this
again
back into the wolfstein we go
skip that cutscene it's glorious but
i've already seen it we've got business
oh you're there already okay waiting
i don't like you you're mean i think
that's fair
maybe i i can outrun it
open faster please
okay all right awesome all right
so here's the sound's gone
so redirecting the thermal fuel let's
follow it and see where it goes yeah you
can actually follow that pipe in the
background and
see what you've done oh no
why no no wow
no no no ah
here comes the dread yes
it's so vicious okay so geeky there
stopped here
which is good i'm just gonna be more
cautious to
make sure he's not anywhere near me
okay
when you finally get out of the emmy
room you feel so
safe but then it's deceiving and
deceiving
yes and you're going to have to go back
in there several times
i don't want to that's not a linear
progression
they need to stop that
get rid of them yeah yeah yeah they are
only trouble if you leave them there
you learn that pretty quick
any more
i love the music it just amplifies
the intensity and it's worth noting for
anybody who's new to the metroid series
that uh this is samus of course and
she's the protagonist in all of the
games so
this might be terribly frightening to us
but this is just a matter of due course
for samus
she has been through a lot and it's just
a testament to
how amazing she is that she's survived
all of it
yeah and even if you may be new to the
franchise
it's totally okay because the game does
a really great job
at giving you um a summary of what has
transpired before
so it's really um it's pretty good easy
to pick up especially if this is your
first game
um in the series um and also if you
don't know who samus is
but you know maybe samus the fighter and
super smash brothers ultimate
same character yeah find out how she
earned her stripes
oh no um
i i just love watching samus slide it's
such a great animation
nope and another way to use your phantom
cloak to get through that door
i don't know if anyone else is
forgetting to breathe remember to
breathe i
i did all right well this statue looks
really mysterious but uh this is the
cliffhanger
we're going to stop here uh because
again we don't
really want to spoil too much of the
story but we wanted to give
you at home a sneak peek of metro dread
we're really excited to play it um we're
really excited for
you guys at home to also get your hands
on when it comes out on
october 10th um or eighth factor eighth
yeah so um but before we go i have a
little surprise to show you
um it is the special edition
version of this game and there it is and
it's glory
yeah and all of its glory you get a
steal book with the game included of
course
and five art cards and an art book which
is really exciting they chronicle
samus's adventures in the 2d games so
like we said whether you
are a long time fan of samus and her
adventures in metroid or you're new to
the series
this is a great way to either celebrate
your fandom or kind of get up to speed
before you play the game so it's really
neat and here it is
yeah all that and the game so mm-hmm
really really cool yeah
it really has something for everyone
action exploration puzzles
samus being cool he's got it all yeah
so um yeah i just wanted to thank again
for the fans for tuning in and uh thanks
for sticking with us this entire time
um yeah if you uh if you missed any of
the
previous segments they're all up on
youtube along with one more segment of a
game that we haven't shown
previously on the stream so be sure to
check that out yeah
on behalf of everyone at nintendo thanks
for watching and
keep smiling
you